[Music]
building a motorcycle
might even have a shrimp steamer
primitive technology great youtube
channel last year if you saw we made a
primtech parody we're making another one
this year and we're brainstorming all
right well what's another goofy
interesting way we can bring our vfx
magic to that genre what are we building
today for some reason clint riding
around a mini bike in his underwear it's
stuck
what can i say we're like what if i'm
making a mini bike to like outrun
zombies
once again another match made in heaven
we were originally just gonna take a
little gas-powered mini bike slap some
bones and straw in there and call it a
day and lo and behold next week boom the
guys from super 73 come by our studio
and they're like hey we want you to trap
these mini bikes they're electric
and they're like oh yeah by the way uh
if you need a custom mini bike for a
video we'll help build any one because
we like your videos
oh hey guys oh what's up oh these are
cool whoa
it took me a second to take it all in
it's like that right in between level
where it's like not quite a motorcycle
but it kind of has that feel and frame
design you feel like you're riding a
motorcycle you don't have to get your
license you don't have to get insurance
it's it's immediate you know instant
gratification
it's an electric mini bike it's gonna be
fine we have to convert one of these
guys into a primitive bike that means we
need to make it look like it's made out
of primitive materials we need them to
make us a stripped version that doesn't
actually have pedals or chains on it i
think what we'll be doing is we're gonna
start off with their basic frame here
their battery etc bamboo pieces
slapping them all over the place because
something very important is going to go
there which is going to be our our clay
steam engine primitive no maybe not
steam it's the pistons bamboo you know
what tbd it's primitive now tomorrow we
get to hop on the phone with them and
they're gonna hopefully kid us out with
a primitive bike i think we're gonna go
for a bamboo finish
today i am tasked with writing prim tech
2 which i am very excited about very
very excited it's something me and sam
collaborated on last year in this one we
want to take it to the next level we're
going to be building a motorcycle it
might even have a shrimp steamer built
into the engine just a little snack you
know don't get my hopes up man i know i
know man it's gonna be a long process to
build a bike to build a combustion
engine right you're gonna need some sort
of fuel source the idea right now is
that you have a zombie press and you
squish these little zombies down into
some sort of reusable energy source so i
have to write the video we were supposed
to start filming this the week after
next week i was hoping to have this idea
basically written by tuesday and it's
already tomorrow's already gonna be
friday it's always about writing i'm
trying to always get better as a writer
and it's the hardest part man it is the
most difficult part not just because
it's a lot of work but because you're
building a puzzle putting the puzzle
together and tearing it apart constantly
and the best videos i think always go
through this process
right now i'm gonna spend three hours or
so writing this script
so the last prim tech video we did
managed to perform fairly well so we're
doing another and clint has taken that
to heart and he thinks the core to that
was the fact that he was in his
underwear the whole time and so he's
going all in and has been wearing
nothing but his underwear the last day
riding this thing and i don't really
think that's like what you should be
only wearing in an office setting like
this i'm like trying to like work on a
video about water and mary is standing
in his underwear so you know what i
thought using the help of bombfell we
might craft some new clothes for clint
while we're at it i might as well uh
craft myself some clothes as well
hey hey clint
i have an idea
i want you to come with me we're gonna
craft you some new clothes
what we're going to do is we're going to
just take what you think best represents
you i want to make some things i guess
i'll grab a drone so for some people
it's kind of a challenge to actually go
and buy clothes for other people to
challenge to wear them at all apparently
fortunately i have a very special recipe
called bombfell which is an easier way
for men to get better looking clothes
every piece of clothing has been
personally picked for you by your own
stylist which leads us to our very first
ingredient the personal touch all right
so clint you just need to add the
personal touch i'm going to add my
personal touch right here so your stylus
is going to email you their selections
based off your preferences and after
that you'll have 48 hours to change your
mind or even cancel it if you want to
you have full control over all of that
so let's get some control in there once
you've received your clothes you have
seven days to notify bonfil which
clothes you want to keep and you can
send the rest back so we're gonna add a
little bit of grass-fed organic control
z and remember the more you keep the
more you save so if you keep four items
you get to save twenty percent three
items fifteen percent and one item you
only save ten percent but that's still
ten percent that you get to keep it's
completely flexible you can receive
clothes when you want and you can pause
or cancel at any time cool now that our
recipe is done it's time to actually hit
craft on these ingredients and form our
clothes and of course we have to add the
rope to tie it all together
oh
it worked uh did you craft a knife we
got to open it can you at least talk now
not until i see the clothes
i said guys look i i'm not gonna wear
pants unless i can do the splits in them
hopefully they heard me and i can do the
splits in these paints
ow is this an army vest did you actually
get a suit trench coat dude oh man i'm
down it's always got a hood
krampus
clint
you're supposed to put the shirt on
first oh i got excited look at that most
of my wardrobe is like quarter merch or
cinnamon for t-shirts
so it's nice to have some nice formal
stuff i'm i'm a big fan of like the slim
cut design you know now really gates
really i'm a little village
they're actually they're actually not
bad these are not magnets
i can stretch in these things on the
ultimate test here we go here we go
yo it works i can do the splits in these
things
dude yes yes
yes
yes
guys if you're trying to get yourself a
bomb bell drop you can because
that is the closest camera hold on so
corridor and bombfell did a little
dealer daily we got you guys 25 off your
own bomb fill drop just go to bombfell
go to bobville.com corridor crew so that
is b-o-m-b-f
e-l-l.com corridor crew and get
yourselves 25 off your first bombfell
purchase
are we doing it like that
yeah regardless here's my idea so you
know you're talking about having a
zombie press right a zombie what a
zombie press for oil for the whole you
press the oils out of the zombies to
fuel your
internal kombucha
engine imagine this right you have like
your cylinder
thing and then you have like your layers
of your filters all your different
filters and it has there's a crank on it
which you pull the crank in it
pushes the thing now it's a hand crank
right you throw the zombie stakes in
there from the first video oh yeah oh we
we turn them in the stakes first we take
the snakes from the first video put them
in crank it it does that like espresso
thing that you showed me where like can
mount that to the side of the bike and
you have it like with like a little like
dust pan on the ground so you have your
bamboo poles on the front that are
popping zombies like
and you poop into steaks some of them
get scooped up into the dustpan and
you sell it as
crafting an autom an auto fueling
motorcycle it's part of the bike okay
that's that's my idea that's a crazy
idea clint's got a couple ideas on it i
think he wants to try to put it into one
video though which i don't really think
is very practical or very good use of
our time because think about the world
of primitive technology people are used
to digesting individual builds out of
this like same camp basically so anyway
i think if we split them up into
multiple videos people will be able to
follow the builds a little bit better if
the payoff of the first video being the
motorcycle and the payoff of the second
video being the motorcycle this is
you're just doing the same thing twice
so it's yeah i understand that the
second video is not actually about the
bike second video is about the press and
the bike is the motive for the press
what's the payoff
payoff is the giant press system just
like the meat harvester it's like a
press here that has a lever here and a
thing here and then a giant thing drops
and then guts fill out and they get
captured in like little things and they
drain down and they run in and then it
goes up back up something and it like
mixes it you know and then and then it
like dribbles out
fuel into like a gas tank also it gives
us more ability to play you know if we
have other ideas about things that we
want to make there's not this huge
expectation to make like a 20 minute
long video where we build like five
different things and it's like this
whole tied up story it's like we can
break it down into digestible videos
that people can watch for five minutes
at a time i feel like it's fighting the
format a little bit to try to do it all
in one video that's the payoff is that
you see this whole thing
working and then
you you use it on the bike
yeah i like the image of it going in
this giant thing three separate liquids
zombie blood going down it down into a
tube refinery
that is it's a refinery it's like a
press and a refinery yeah
building a zombie blood refinery yeah
okay that makes sense that makes sense
that two video idea makes sense
this already has a nice big rack ready
to go that's part of this and we just
need the bar
regardless both bikes would need to be
modded of course yeah i
i like this one because it's a little
bit bigger and already has some of the
features we're looking for and i i know
i understand that's an issue and this is
an issue you can cover it up with some
leaves our call at 1 30 again
but your guys call up at 1 30 is to talk
about getting a custom bike for this
project seeing if they can uh basically
strip this down and install a feature or
two for us they talked some big talk
when they were here like anything you
guys want we'll make it yeah we can make
you a custom one blah blah i think
they'll be able to do and they'll be
able to tell us what they can do i'm
just i don't know their timeline yeah
okay
so we just got off the phone with them
and we delivered our plan of action
which removes removing the bike pedals
getting a custom paint job applying a
higher output non-stick legal motor
installing a cessy bar and maybe
extending the racks stripping it of all
unnecessary electronics like the
headlights and stuff like that fenders
etc they're all definitely down
so i'm really excited
but at the button of the conversation is
a little unfortunate which is that
they've just moved
like offices and they weren't expecting
us to like call them back within a week
and go okay we have an idea and we need
your help and uh they're still moving
into their new location their
fabrication shop isn't complete
basically ian was like yeah this all
sounds doable and how long when you want
to shoot with this i'm going to two
weeks he's like ah
okay
uh
yeah i don't know we'll uh
we'll see if we can do so if this works
out it's gonna be a really great video
and if it doesn't
well you'll just have to wait and see
what we did instead
or how we figured it out
we always do
[Applause]
you have to keep that in for sure dude
that's going in the blooper of